[Music]
foreign
we learned that you can modernize your
legacy workflow management and data
orchestration pipelines in Google Cloud
today we'll dive a little deeper in one
such use case on how Tech Solutions one
of our technology Partners migrated and
autosis workload to Cloud composer and
helped unlock technology and cost
benefits for one of our customers let's
welcome Tim who's the chief technology
officer at Tech Solutions
thanks for having me here today
so Tim tell us more about what you're
going to share with our audience today
sure I would love to
for the agenda today I'm going to share
the customer challenges the migration
strategy I will walk you through a
reference architecture and then we'll go
over the Lessons Learned amazing could
you share with us what were some
challenges that they were running into
like a lot of customers they have
thousands of jobs that do complex tasks
and are being run in Old Legacy on-prem
environments the systems are expensive
from both the licensing and support
perspective and the jobs are typically
Mission critical for the business this
presents a major challenge for the
business as the job complexity grows and
scalability becomes a real problem
couple this with the fact that there are
no clear modernization paths from the
cloud for these Legacy systems and our
customers are stuck having an option
like Cloud composer presents a
relatively easy path to the cloud
hmm with such a huge workload how did
you go about with the migration
since no one had ever done this before
we first needed to calculate the ROI you
know I.E feature spend versus what
they're currently spending on the
support and the licenses this yielded
about a 45 cost saving compared to the
the current costs there are way too many
auto assist jobs to be migrated manually
so we needed an automated process for
this and that really was the magic
behind this we built out an application
that would handle the conversion process
and when we started to boil this down we
started to see some patterns that we
could repeat these patterns were the
basis to which we started to migrate the
jobs over once we were able to convert a
few jobs we started to gain some
confidence in the Automation and
Unleashed it onto the bulk of the jobs
the last remaining piece where the
integration touch points and quality
testing these last two steps were manual
but had to be done manually just to make
sure that the tools were solving the
problems that we brought them to do
could you also shared with us that
reference architecture on how it would
look on Google Cloud yes definitely this
architecture assumes that we've already
converted the jobs into dag files and
that they're already stored in a Google
Cloud Storage bucket we have a schedule
here that will operate on some frequency
depending on the job and for every job
will spawn an operator and a sensor the
operator will fire and forget the job
while the sensor will track the status
of the gel completion the state of how
the job is performing is stored in the
sqla database and the custom agent will
do the job that was defined in the dag
file for every job type we have a
utility script that will operate its job
function and most likely call out to
different integration points things like
SSL and odbc database calls wow with all
these migration efforts could you also
share with us why should customers think
of moving to Cloud composer and what are
some benefits that they can unlock
when considering Cloud composer things
like ease of use and integration are
always major considerations since time
is money with workflow automation across
different Industries Cloud composer has
a clear advantage over less Legacy
Technologies because one it's easy to
learn and it's managed service so which
means it's constantly being updated and
run for you you've got a lot more
flexibility in how you do alerting and
when a problem occurs since you have
that flexibility you can easily identify
where it is you can have a much smaller
support team regardless of the size of
the environment which runs Cloud
composer second scalability integration
are a major pulling of the cloud
composer as there are a ton of
out-of-the-box capabilities that work
with Cloud composer with far more
integration tools through airflow you
can customize your data pipelines as you
need them and finally cost Legacy tools
like autosys require expensive licensing
and specific engine Engineers to handle
the support running in a managed service
like Cloud composer frees you the burden
of supporting infrastructure and you're
only paying for the consumption that
you're using for your jobs costs become
even higher when you need to replace
your auto assist experts the pool of
Jill experts is dwindling and fewer
young programmers are learning it you
know that puts the remaining experts in
a higher demand which means higher
salaries if you can even find them in
the first place
thanks Tim that was so helpful thank you
for walking us through this sample use
case you too can modernize your legacy
workloads to Google Cloud head to
cloud.google.com to learn more don't
forget to subscribe for more such Google
cloud content thanks for watching
[Music]